I grew up in western Colorado and we
prided ourselves on being Westerners
every time I come south I realized the
place where I grew up was south but like
schizoid about it and never owned up to
the fact that the psychology of North
Carolina is more what western Colorado
is about than the psychology is done in
California by any stretch anyway not to
wander I grew up in this place and I was
curious and I think curiosity is the
psychedelic virtue it's the precondition
for finding your way into the presence
of this answer intellectual curiosity
and I was told well you know there were
dinosaurs here a hundred million years
ago and fifty million years before that
there was an ocean here and we would go
out into the dry Arroyo and sandstone
country and here would be these
seashells and spiral ammonites and stuff
and I was obsessed with the sea because
I had never seen it I didn't see the
ocean till I was 14 years old and yet
here was evidence of the ocean in some
of the driest and most shattered desert
country you could ever see and so I if I
got the message and the message is the
world is not what it appears to be where
there are deserts one find evidence of
ocean where there are waste lands one
finds evidence of jungle and by
extension where there is love one can
uncover animosity and conflict where
there is faith one can uncover love and
community so very early I got the notion
things are not as the
I appear to be
[Music]